Oh, mais qu’est-ce que tu fais ?
Mais t’es mignonne Léa en Panda.
C’est vrai que vous êtes mignonnes avec vos pyjamas d’animaux disparus là.
- Mais...
- Ah c'est un pyjama, OK
Moi j’ai pas du tout disparu,
les hommes me trouvent beaucoup trop mignonne.
Oh ça va, le melon là, ça se passe comment.
Mais non, ça n’a rien à voir.
Début 2019, est sorti un article compilant les résultats de 73 études publiées depuis 40 ans sur l’état de la biodiversité.
Et le constat est alarmant.
Aujourd'hui, environ un tiers des espèces sont menacées d'extinction et chaque année environ 1% supplémentaire s'ajoute à la liste.
Mais si je vous demande de me citer une espèce menacée, vous me citerez sûrement
l’ours polaire, le tigre peut-être, le panda,...
bref, des mammifères, mignons et emblématiques.
Et ce n’est pas anodin, ces espèces sont ce que l’on appelle des espèces charismatiques.
Le biologiste Frank Courchamp s’est justement attaché à définir une liste de ces espèces qui profitent d’une grande visibilité médiatique.
Il a d’abord demandé aux internautes de lister ces animaux.
Puis, il a posé la même question à des écoliers en Angleterre, en Espagne et en France.
Et enfin, il a répertorié tous les animaux sauvages qui étaient sur les affiches des films d’animations de Disney, Pixar et Dreamworks,
ainsi que tous les animaux figurant sur la page d’accueil des zoos des 100 plus grandes villes du monde.
Résultat : les dix animaux sauvages les plus charismatiques sont
le tigre, le lion, l’éléphant, la girafe, le léopard, le panda, le guépard, l’ours polaire, le loup et le gorille.
Sauf qu’il y a tout un autre pan de la biodiversité souvent oubliée, qui disparaît aujourd'hui en silence : les insectes.
Au total, sur la base de toutes ces études, les auteurs montrent que la proportion d’espèces en déclin
s’élève à 41 % pour les insectes, soit une proportion deux fois plus grande que les vertébrés.
Et les causes principales du déclin des insectes sont clairement établies :
- la disparition des milieux naturels (par l’agriculture, l’urbanisation…)
- les polluants (fertilisants, pesticides, etc...)
- les facteurs biologiques (introduction d’espèces envahissantes ou de pathogènes...)
- et, enfin, le changement climatique.
Mais voilà, qui s’émeut du déclin des insectes ?
Qui milite pour la sauvegarde des termites ou des mouches ?
Pourtant, leur disparition entraîne irrémédiablement la disparition de leurs  prédateurs,
cause des problèmes de pollinisation, d'appauvrissement des sols, etc.
Est-ce que nous aurions un biais dans nos choix de notre sauvegarde de la biodiversité ?
Tu vas parler de biais cognitif ?
Oui ! Je suis en train de me demander si on aurait pas tendance à sauvegarder certaines espèces juste parce qu’on les trouve mignonnes,
sans tenir compte de leur importance dans l‘écosystème.
Une équipe de chercheurs français a justement essayé de voir si notre perception de la beauté du vivant était en accord avec les fonctions écologiques des espèces.
L’équipe du biologiste Nicolas Mouquet a mis au point une méthode permettant de mesurer la valeur esthétique des poissons tropicaux.
Ils ont demandé à plus de 8 000 personnes, de 3 à 80 ans, de choisir entre 2 photos de poisson l’espèce qu’ils trouvaient la plus belle.
Ils ont ensuite évalué le rôle de chaque espèce dans l’écosystème en fonction de ses caractéristiques.
Ils ont ainsi pu montrer que les espèces les plus belles, les plus attractives aux yeux des personnes consultées, jouent rarement un rôle clé dans l’écosystème.
Plus précisément les espèces les moins jolies étaient 33% plus utiles à l’écosystème que les espèces les plus jolies.
Cette recherche s’est transformée en une étude participative plus vaste et s’étend désormais aux insectes et aux orchidées.
D’ailleurs, si vous voulez y participer le lien est en description.
T’as raison, c’est carrément un biais cognitif.
On ne doit pas se baser juste sur le côté esthétique des animaux, s’ils sont beaux ou pas.
Le fait d’être mignon, bah ça ne change rien sur la position dans l’écosystème.
Ça doit changer dans l’évolution des espèces.
Je pense que ça doit être un avantage évolutif à être mignon.
Ou plutôt le contraire…
C’est à dire ?
Kringelbach 2016, la mignonitude, ça se passe dans le cerveau des parents.
Cette étude, elle décrit que, c’est pas tellement les animaux qui ont été sélectionnés de plus en plus mignons,
c’est plutôt le cerveau des parents qui a subi une pression évolutive.
Les parents qui étaient du genre à trouver leurs enfants plus mignons s’en sont plus occupés, ils ont eu plus de chance de survie.
Alors que les groupes sociaux qui étaient moins du genre à trouver leurs bébés mignons…
Ils les laissaient crever.
- Probablement.
- Ok, oui, donc du coup,
c’est un avantage évolutif de trouver ses enfants mignons.
C’est un avantage évolutif de trouver ses propres enfants mignons.
Ça aide à perpétuer ses gènes.
- D'accord.
- Et parmi les espèces qui sont mignonnes aujourd’hui,
y a les animaux domestiques par exemple.
Les chiens, les chats qu’on a aujourd’hui, ils existaient pas à la Préhistoire.
C’est plutôt les loups qui se sont auto-domestiqués.
Ceux qui avaient des têtes les moins repoussantes, qui étaient un peu les plus mignons,
bah du coup, ils ont eu un avantage évolutif parce qu’ils étaient plus acceptés dans des communautés humaines,
et du coup, ils ont plus pu profiter des restes des êtres-humains.
Et du coup, là c’est clairement, il valait mieux être mignon pour survivre.
À ce moment-là précis, pour un loup, il valait mieux carrément être mignon pour survivre.
Et après coup, l’espèce humaine a carrément pris les choses en main.
On a fait se reproduire des portées et on a choisi les individus les plus mignons,
les plus dociles pour pouvoir se faire reproduire, et en quelques milliers d’années,
l’espèce a carrément évolué jusqu’au petit chihuahua trop mignon avec les couettes qu’on a aujourd’hui.
C’est probablement pour ça que Glitch, il est aussi mignon aujourd’hui.
On peut aussi se demander si du côté des études en biologie, certains animaux ne concentreraient pas plus l’attention que d’autres.
Le bio informaticien Julien Troudet a récemment essayé de quantifier ce biais a partir des données du Système mondial d’Information sur la Biodiversité.
Cette bibliothèque open access et participative rassemble au niveau mondial, des données sur la présence et la localisation des êtres vivants,
depuis les spécimens recensés dans les musées jusqu’aux photos géolocalisées des naturalistes amateurs.
Ces données sont la matière première utilisée dans tous les domaines de la recherche en biodiversité.
- Pffff, j'ai chaud
- Met du vent dedans, voilà.
L’analyse de plus de 600 millions de données animales et végétales a montré de grands écarts entre les espèces répertoriées.
Il y a plus de 370 données par espèce pour la moitié des oiseaux, et seulement 3 données pour la moitié des insectes.
Les chercheurs formulent donc une hypothèse sociétale.
Au delà des facteurs pratiques (genre facilité d’observation, accès au terrain, obtention de financements),
les organismes les plus étudiés seraient ceux préférés par la population.
Double peine donc, pour les animaux moches.
Non seulement le grand public et les politiques sont moins investis dans les programmes de sauvegarde,
mais en plus, ils sont moins étudiées.
Sauf que ce sont sur ces connaissances que doivent s’appuyer les programmes de conservation de la biodiversité.
A ce jour, les scientifiques ont répertorié environ 2 millions d’espèces vivantes,
ce qui ne correspond en fait qu’à une toute petite partie de la biodiversité réellement présente sur Terre.
Selon les biologistes Paul Olivier et Michael Lee, le nombre d’espèces sur Terre serait plus proche de 100 millions.
Déjà parce qu’on connaît encore très mal la biodiversité des microrganismes,
mais aussi parce que la plus grande partie des espèces répertoriées jusqu’à présent est basée sur une description morphologique des individus.
Les analyses ADN permettent désormais de distinguer de nouvelles espèces, car chacune représente un patrimoine génétique particulier qui évolue indépendamment.
Le cas extrême, ce sont les espèces cryptiques.
Extérieurement, les individus sont très semblables, sauf qu’en réalité, ils appartiennent à des groupes différents qui ne se reproduisent jamais entre eux.
Et manque de pot, en croisant les études génétiques, écologiques et de terrain,
un grand nombre d’espèces décrites jusqu’à présent, se révèlent être constituées de plusieurs espèces cryptiques.
Par exemple, les scientifiques viennent tout juste de réaliser que les éléphants africains,
qui sont pourtant des espèces charismatiques, ne sont probablement pas une seule et même espèce, mais deux espèces cryptiques :
l’éléphant de la savane et l’éléphant de la forêt.
Et il ne s’agit pas seulement d’obtenir le nombre exact d’espèces.
Les lacunes dans notre connaissance de la biodiversité pourraient avoir des répercussions sur nos méthodes de conservation.
Pour reprendre l’exemple de l’éléphant, ne sachant pas qu’il s’agit de deux espèces distinctes, nous pourrions choisir
de laisser mourir les éléphants dans la forêt, tant que nous en voyons dans la savane, pensant simplement qu’il s’agit d’un déplacement de leur habitat.
Et en essayant de réintroduire dans la foret des éléphants de la savane,
nous serions surpris de voir qu’ils ne se reproduisent pas entre eux !
La solution serait donc de médiatiser et promouvoir les espèces moins charismatiques.
C’est une tâche qui pourrait incomber plutôt aux chercheurs
mais il faut également que le grand public s’ouvre à leur charme particulier et aux récits passionnants les concernant.
Les spécialistes du ver de terre par exemple, les géodriologues comme on les appelle,
ont pu attirer l’attention sur ces petits animaux dont la population a été divisée par 10 depuis les années 50.
La campagne de communication “Sauvons le ver de terre” a réhabilité ces invertébrés aveugles, sourds et visqueux
en montrant combien ils sont indispensables à la bonne santé des sols.
Mais même en rendant certains animaux méconnus plus visibles dans les médias,
ça n’est pas gagné.
Au contraire même.
En réalisant ces études sur les animaux charismatiques,
le biologiste Frank Courchant a noté que les gens avaient une très mauvaise perception du danger d’extinction encouru par ces animaux.
Saviez-vous que les lions pourraient disparaître dans vingt ans si rien n’est fait ?
Ou que la girafe est une espèce en voie de disparition ?
Selon le chercheur, le fait de voir autant de girafes et d’autres animaux charismatiques dans les médias donne l’impression que ces espèces ne sont pas en danger.
- Biais cognitif.
- Ouais !
Du coup, est-ce que les sciences de la conservation font ce qu’il faut pour encourager la sauvegarde la biodiversité ?
Les chercheurs Laurent Godet et Vincent Devictor ont analysé le contenu de 13 000 articles publiés entre 2000 et 2015 par les biologistes de la conservation.
Après avoir mis de côté les articles de discussions internes à la discipline,
ils ont classé les études en trois catégories :
l’état de la biodiversité, les menaces qui pèsent sur celle-ci et les solutions possibles.
Bon, sur l’état de la biodiversité, ça pas de surprise le tableau est globalement négatif.
Mais le coté positif est que cette enquête identifie 14 types de mesures différentes efficaces
et montre que des solutions durables et compatibles avec les activités humaines existent.
On peut restaurer des écosystèmes tout en maintenant de l’agriculture, par exemple en en ne déviant que partiellement un cours d’eau.
Le frein majeur reste la demande de compromis toujours plus favorables à l’exploitation plutôt qu’à la conservation.
Il faut donc maintenant que les solutions scientifiques diffusent dans la société, vers le grand public et les décideurs politiques.
Finalement, même si on doit pas s’en contenter pour définir nos politiques de conservation de la biodiversité,
notre sensibilité esthétique peut tout de même être un moteur à notre envie de protéger le vivant.
C’est la conclusion de la philosophe de l’environnement Virginie Maris.
Il n’y a pas que ce qui est beau et que ce qui nous émeut, qui mérite une certaine considération.
Merci à vous les mignons d’avoir regardé cet épisode du Vortex.
Abonnez-vous, laissez un commentaire, rejoignez-nous sur le Discord. Et je vous dis, à très vite.
Léa, tu penses que tu vas survivre toi ?